l'équipage du concorde se prépare le
grand jour c'est mercredi le
supersonique reprendra son premier vol
commercial avec des passagers à bord
près d'un an et demi après la
catastrophe de gonesse un vol qu'ils ont
préparée pendant de longs mois en
modifiant l'appareil et en s'entraînant
sur des simulateurs de vol le reportage
de patrick esther eric jamais depuis la
fin de l'été un certain nombre de vols
de concorde ont eu lieu sans passager
vol d'essai pour valider les
modifications techniques mais aussi vol
d'entraînement qui ont permis aux
pilotes de retrouver leur qualification
en vol durant ces longs mois où le
supersonique est resté cloué au sol les
équipages sont toujours rester dans
l'ambiance très particulière du cockpit
confort notamment grâce aux séances de
simulateur
les équipes sont constituées au total
d'une trentaine de mécaniciens de
pilotes et de commandant de bord en
maintenant une douzaine d'entre eux est
parti en retrait 6 co pilote sont
également passés comme amber sur 777
patrice la personne copilote depuis huit
ans a choisi lui de rester sur concorde
0 j'ai trouvé très honnête d'euros
piloté cet avion tels que je les
laissais de pouvoir l'euro piloté
pendant un certain temps et ensuite de
me poser la question pour ma place pour
changer de place et passer commande en
bord une forme de fidélité c'est une
finalité manette des gaz à fond
attention concorde s'élance sur la piste
et d'écoles le simulateur est une copie
fidèle du cockpit un léger tremblement
le mur du son va être passée ici
l'ordinateur en place l'avion et génère
toutes sortes de situations d'urgence
panne de moteur ou d'entrées d'air et
même le cas le pire cabine est
incontrôlable dépressurisation de la
cabine à 18 mètres d'altitude ce qui
oblige les pilotes à enfiler les masques
à oxygène à aucun moment pourtant c'est
au moment du retour en vol de concorde
moi j'ai toujours cru au redémarrage de
cet avion
l'inconnue était la date évidemment
puisqu'on ne maîtrise pas tous les
éléments mais dès le départ en
connaissant les raisons vrai
de l'arrêt de l'accident je sais penser
qu'il n'y avait aucune raison pour que
l'avion ne révèle pas un jour et pour
que l'appareil revol il a fallu former
de nouveaux personnels pendant sept ans
mais bien six de nos camarades
mécaniciens sont partis à la retraite et
qu'il a fallu donc les remplacer plus
bien sûr celui qui a disparu
malheureusement dans l'accident faut
dire en plus du maintien des compétences
des équipages déjà qualifiés il a fallu
former de nouveaux équipages ainsi
l'unique simulateur de concorde n'a
jamais autant travaillé que durant
l'année écoulée